pourtant je parle pas de moi j'essaie de
réduire mes interventions je comprends
pas la star internationale est donc
revenu dans une interview sur sa
nouvelle vie depuis la mort de rené et
il expliqué tout simplement en standing
tourisme
je commence à voir je ne sais pas
comment on peut dire ça des propos qui
ont choqué énormément de fans lui
reprochant notamment d'avoir même trahi
son mari et même vis-à-vis des enfants
et bien voilà une deuxième fois et deux
fois rené regardé plusieurs enfants
derrière vous oublie pas céline dion est
de retour et elle compte bien le faire
savoir
la semaine dernière en couverture du
magazine gala
la diva tourner définitivement la page
en quelques mots maintenant je suis le
poste de ma fille trois ans après la
mort de rené céline dion veut donc tout
changé dans sa vie et elle met le paquet
fini le kitsch du césar palace de las
vegas direction la route 66 pour un clip
déjanté avec toute son équipe et surtout
ep munoz celui dont on a si longtemps
cru qu'il était son amant goran fan de
mode elle pose dans des tenues chaque
fois plus excentriques et se moque de
son statut de star de rennes dira comme
un cv
comme la semaine dernière sur le plateau
de jimmy kimmel où elle s'amuse à marier
un couple à las vegas énorme surprise
énorme coup de feu de six
bon vent
tu peux trouver des sikhs
car céline est aussi en pleine promo
pour son nouvel album avec ditto
beaucoup de surprises
david guetta battre avec vous quand même
ça on a vu passer cette information vous
à une autre question
alors changement de look de stratégie et
de musique céline dion trahi telle la
mémoire de rené
[Applaudissements]
ah les [ __ ] ça qu'ils vont avoir
[Musique]
où
oh
[Applaudissements]
sur le canton était en débardeur et
qu'on s'éclate et je mets pas en
débardeur annonces chiffrées le jour je
passerai des vacances avec toi je te
jure je tenais quand on a la caméra qu
aux boutures que bradley sa tournée
caunes et en direct
évidemment font mentir on n'aime payer
ses impôts on est de gauche si on aime
magali bertin mon coeur on passera des
vacances ensemble je te prends mais tu
me dis ça c'est vrai il ya des oui mais
non c'est très très mitigé je vais vous
laisser parler parce que moi au fond de
moi ça me rase mais un truc de deux jeux
pour faire d'enfant est tous très vite
elle renaît on va commencer par daniel
moreau qui forcément un très proche de
rené
[Applaudissements]
alors les affaires de prêtres est tel
rené ala déclaré clarence à vivre moi
j'ai mal à mon âme de midinette parce
que quoi qu'elle dise qu'elle est le
nouveau boss de sa vie c'est vrai
qu'elle a pu être un peu étouffé tout ça
mais je commence à vivre ces lignes on
commence à vie mais j'ai c'est la seule
en fait je crois qui me faisait croire
qu'on pouvait avoir un amour unique
c'est évidemment le premier rameur de sa
vie et elle nous a joué la comédie du
bonheur aux côtés de la france parce que
la phrase laisse entendre si on parle un
petit peu français est coupé de la
rhétorique réthoré toi rhétorique
je commence enfin à vivre ça fait
longtemps avant je ne vivais pas là
est-ce qu'elle a trahi rené pardon j'ai
faire des gens je veux faire parler des
gens qui pensent qu'elle l'a trahi parce
que c'est mon avis et du coup je n'ai
rien mais moi je trouve que c'est hyper
dur notamment pour ses enfants bien sûr
qu'elle trahit rooney ce qu'elle
emprunte de dire c'est qu'avant elle l'a
même dit dans le magnéto
je suis maintenant la bosse de mal à les
assumer
c'est hyper dur que ces enfants que ça
veut dire qu'en fait avant eux rené
ilham était sous son joug qu'elles
peuvent et veulent se permet et que du
coup maintenant elle en fait elle est
enfin voir ce que ça veut dire que leur
personnel
ça veut dire que le père de ses enfants
finalement bas ils n'étaient pas super
quoi est ce qu'elle va dire qu'il va
exporter qu'il soit parti balad vie mais
ça fait 40 ans que j'attendais ça un
méchant parler les gens les halles elle
n'a jamais dit qu'elle n'aimait pas
rôdés guillaume oui toute sa vie depuis
qu'elle a 12 ans et est avec rené sous
sa coupe et autres bons ya là elle l
aimait cet homme elle l'est mais elle
n'a jamais dit je ne les aime plus
c'était un enfer avec renée elle dit
juste que c'était une autre vie c'était
avant 10 ans connaissait pas bien pas du
tout l avenir et son manager parce que
elle veut être libre elle avait un
manager qui avaient été imposées par
rené qui sentimentalement ne lui a mené
parce que rld et lui amenaient et puis
aujourd'hui elle a décidé d'être une
femme libre après un dos et c'est mon
cas ok ok rachel quand on a eu des
longues relations et voilà le canton et
plex la personne n'aime pas qu'est ce
qu'on dit je revis dans le mail
quand ça se passe mais pas quand tu es
mort de valade sud est où l'autre côté
tu sais tu te rends tu t'ouvres haleine
tout le temps car elle va se reposer
vous des bons profils la fauv llc avait
dégagé par diana était bavard elle va
être frisquet bon alors il vous dit que
les atouts dur pour les volets montrer
vos années de suite que tu nous dis des
choses et tu les fais pas ça s'appelle
que de la gueule ouais c'est ubu ces bib
je suis sûr kim ki nam et l'affiché
passionne pour le coup pardon est
vraiment et j'aime bien vécu avec
mathieu on a souvent le même avis et non
en tant que journalistes tous trop
gentil j'ai envie de vous dire parler de
rené comme juste son amour mais c'est
pas que son amour si son manager c'est
son producteur aujourd'hui elle le
trahit doublement en ne posant un
personnage qu'elle incarne qui n'a rien
à voir avec celui qu'elle était à vendre
donc si une double trahison elle trahit
la raison pour laquelle pourquoi les
plus le public avec céline dion
parce que sa stratégie a prôné c'était
d'en faire une femme simple proche de
son public pas trop sophistiqué qui gèle
en train de faire exactement l'inversé
le tue une deuxième phase de jeu de l'un
par l'ats catherine mais pensez juste
quand même aussi je donne juste une
petite piste penser aux enfants qui a
entendu son égérie voilà ce qu'est qui
va dire peut-être maman mais tu vivais
pas que papa former un méchant mais il
avait bien mis un coup de coeur pour
cette raison le trail aussi musicalement
maintenant elle fait de la techno élèves
ils n'auraient jamais supporter ça il a
fait d'ailleurs elle vend beaucoup moins
de disques on entend parler plus pour
ses frasques que pour ses albums ce qui
est quand même un site incroyable et
elle le trahit doublement à cause de ça
quand tu viens au monsieur que johnny
van ark est mort elle est toujours dit
sans lui je ne vis plus sans lui je ne
suis plus rien l'hôtel dit maintenant je
m'éclate
qu'elle paraît aussi qu'elle parle de
paiement à l'aller du 5 ou 6 dernières
années de sa vie etc rené elle était
avec un manga malades en phase terminale
donc mais c'est bien sûr que oui donc
quand elle dit qu'elle revient c'est
aussi qu'elle sort
non mais quel sens ils étaient six ans a
terminé huile a eu un cancer des années
non mais c'est bien sûr il y ait la main
à leur vie parce qu'elle s'est libéré
taille le dit dans l'interview des je
suis libéré de la maladie de rené ménard
messieurs c'est qu'ils souffrent plus
dans ses derniers mots vous devez
simplement elle a fini son deuil en fait
c'est tout et aujourd'hui elle est plus
heureux ça se sent mieux et à l'eau et
elle mais qui dut dans ce cas là je
redémarre une vie oui bah je revis en
allant chez elle elle et elle vient de
passer dixième des années hyper
douloureuse et elle a pleuré tout son
corps et là vous mais ça tient pas
compte rendu à mozilla tiendra
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui elle est juste elle a passé
peut-être le cap après olonzagais magali
ton argument tient bray si elle s'était
comporté comme ça il ya 15 ans avant
qu'il soit malade pour que les crises il
a toujours été là jamais un truc
important c'est qu'elle est mise sous
cloche depuis qu'elle a 14 ans de makala
14 ans elle avait droit
elle est sous les ordres de rené l a
jamais eu son mot à dire des comptes
elle sait jamais éclaté pense pas que
rooney était le mec le plus drôle de la
ville l'essentiel est qu'on fait la
connaissance
bah voilà on essaie de fil des sondages
sondages enfin je vis et d'une traité le
roi
[Applaudissements]